You are listening to radiolab radiolab
from w n y. S e
n n p. R. A logo. This is Jim Dickson speaking. Hello Dr. Dickson.
My name is Soren. I'm your, I'm the producer for today.
You'll actually be talking to our host Jad.
He's on his way over to the studios right now, so that's good. All right,
so let's just start the story here. This is a bit of tape we've had for awhile.
Uh, it's just kind of fun. It'll lead into the story in a second. Hello,
Dr. Dickson.
Hello judge. Hi, how are you? I'm very well, thank you.
I'm always pleased to talk about my delightful obsession of hard for more than
10 years. Um, related to my mileage to a French lady.
I'm not joking. How does the marriage to the French lady, uh, factor in? Ah,
well you, we, we met on email. Huh?
A bit like you've got mail and you know the, the Hollywood film.
Well, I mean, my wife was, uh,
my wife is sitting beside me and she's making signals.
What does it you'll see in India? Can I, can I ask,
is there any chance we could talk to your wife if she says yes,
he wants to talk to you. Do you come on. Hello.
Hi.
I am French and my English is not very x. No,
you're fantastic.
You mentioned that let's was what brought you together. Yes, it's true.
I was a teacher, a high school teacher.
She emailed me some questions about yes and I answered them to the best of my
ability and shortly after we were married, no kings.
So C is my benefactor, my friend.
Okay. So we'll, we should introduce ourselves real fast. I'm Jad. I am Robert.
This is radio lab, the podcast. And so, uh, that Guy Jim Dixon,
Lee's a botanist, call him four years ago to talk about this fellow. Let's see.
We're going to tell it what's his story and completely in just a second.
But there's something in the whole interaction between him and his wife there
that just kind of captures how everybody gets when they get into Etsy. They guy,
they get married, their, they get obsessed,
but it wasn't until very recently are producing any mills.
And I happened to talk to this graphic artist named Aaron Berg,
who is also totally obsessed with this guy. Yes.
I think there's this hunger on the part of the reason that's when we really
understood what this story is all about. Yeah. I mean, at least for me,
that's where it all started it since Andy's been reporting this piece,
why don't, and you just, you just take the ball from here. Okay. Do it Andy.
So story starts 1991 way up in the alley.
3,210 meters above sea level.
I know you Americans don't think in meters.
That's roughly 10 and a half thousand feet.
This is a frozen glacial spot and up there walking around,
we're two hill walkers, two hill walkers, hikers, height curves.
I was a German couple. I'm an NYU.
It was early in the afternoon and at
some point they take a notion to head off trail. I know we're
only a hundred yards off the beaten track and after just a few minutes,
they round a little rock and that's when they were
stopped dead in their tracks. By what? By a corpse.
Scopes sticking out of the ice.
[inaudible]
he was lying on his stomach face down in the ice.
He was kind of draped over a big boulder.
His legs are buried under the ice,
up to his hips and his top half is just sticking out.
Left arm is kind of under his forehead, almost like a,
a schoolboy falling asleep in class on his arm.
So these two hikers, they see this and they run off
for help.
The hot footie tip to the nearby mountain hut thinking it was not meant to
needing accident. A recent one, they called the police. He said, hey, somebody,
a tourist or a climber had some sort of accident.
And so the cops showed up with drills and ice picks and started to chip away at
the ice trying to get the body out, but then
started noticing some things like this guy had
all these tattoos on his back and the behind his knees.
Then they start noticing all this stuff buried with him.
He's got some kind of Moccasin,
looks like ox skin behind her bare skin cop. Unusual stuff.
He had a copper headed, you have to X. Oh, what?
A small pouch filled with medicinal tree fungus quiver full of arrows.
A long bull. He had grass socks. Ras Sucks,
woven grass. A dagger that has been chipped out of stone.
And so these cops realize that this is not a 20th century tourist who,
who wandered off trail. This was something extraordinary. This is old.
Uh Huh.
Like renaissance or old. Middle Ages are old,
but wouldn't we like to know? And what did the police do? Well,
the police are reported to the forensic authorities in the University of Ns
group.
Basically they took it to a team of local scientists who sent samples out to a
bunch of labs and eventually confirmed that, yeah, this is old,
but not just old. This was really old.
This body is 5,300 years old.
Wow.
Yes. That's way before Jesus.
Way before most of you are to use as a historic mark point. Let's say the,
the Pyramids of Egypt. Uh,
this would be 700 years prior to the construction of the pyramid at Giza.
It was beyond archeologist, wildest dreams.
5,200 year old, perfectly preserved.
Cops were talking about a man with all his skin, with his eyeballs, his teeth,
his, his groin,
his organs, his guts. Everything's in there.
Everything is almost perfectly freeze dried. There the is.
So what does it look like? Oh, well,
uh, he was [inaudible] he's 45 years old, which I think for, for, uh,
3000 BC is pretty darn old. Huh. And he was a small guy.
He was only about five foot two and height. But his calf muscles,
his thigh muscles are incredibly developed. Yeah.
So this would suggest that he's a hunter or a shepherd of some kind who walks
these mountains.
His physique is compatible to the modern Olympian wrestler.
Mm.
He was Eddie, obviously a human being.
[inaudible]
very, very obviously. And he would have all the hopes and fears of you and I,
they even gave them a name, Bootsy, Etsy, Etsy, Guzzi.
Even though some of us can't really pronounce that name. Let's see.
Spell it. Oh,
two dots on task scientists call him Bootsy. There's all kinds of drama.
There's, there's Austria competing with Italy. He's our mommy. No,
he's our mommy. He's on the border whose money is eventually the Italians
because he said to be 92 meters inside Italy,
a whole museum is built around him.
An entire facility is built to freeze him. There's teams of researchers,
there's competing universities. You have documentaries,
you have books and articles about this incredible mummy who was walking in the
icy fell. Isn't that fascinating? You know Brad bit, yeah,
he got a tattoo Bootsy on his arm,
but what everyone really wanted to know was this prehistoric person who was this
guy? Where did he come from? Was he a scout? Was he a traveler?
Where was he going? How did he fall? How he died?
Was it a storm that took him on? What was he doing so high in the mountains?
Yeah.
When we found them there really,
there really wasn't any way to answer these kinds of questions.
All you got was wild speculation,
but this is where it becomes more than a story about an ancient dead guy over
the past, what, 22 years since he's been found.
All these researchers keep coming back to [inaudible] and they've gathered just
enough little pieces of evidence that when you put it all together
[inaudible]
what you get is this surprisingly intimate.
Look at this one real person.
Like there's one real dude who lived 5,300 years ago,
and for our purposes,
the first piece of that puzzle falls into place on a summer's Day in 2001 when a
radiologist named Dr. Paul Gossner. Yeah. Is staring at a CT scan,
basically a 3d x ray votes. These chest maybe for the umpteenth time.
For the thousandth time when suddenly, yeah.
[inaudible]
oh,
this is something unusual right up by [inaudible] shoulder blade in the left
scapula. What does he notice? He finds an Arrowhead
[inaudible]
lodged in the shoulder blade and I think it was hard to see because it's stone,
not metal. If it was metal, they would have picked it up right away.
So why does this mean that this is like a possible murder? That's right.
The whole thing blows up to a full scale murder mystery.
From that moment on,
we knew that he was shocked with an Arrow and then it all started the research
about, that's Albert Zinc.
He's actually the top scientists in charge of Odssey these days.
What we do is like doing a crime scene investigation.
We tried to put together not too long after Gossner spotted that arrowhead zinc
and his team, they take out, see if they actually put them into an ambulance,
rushed them as fast as they can to a hospital,
trying to make sure that he doesn't talk and they put them into a higher
resolution.
Full body CT scan and the plot thickens.
Further.
We find severe abdominal wounds and rib fractures,
things that before it may have come across as 5,000 year old wear and tear.
There's an orbital fracture of the cranium.
Now it's like we're seeing them with new eyes. His head is busted
and not only that, right palm is very badly cut.
It's very deep. How deep it's so deep that there's cuts in the underlying bones.
Oh, some pathologist. See it's a defensive. We wouldn't want,
it comes from a fight.
He held his right hand up and he got slashed on his right palm and in trying to
piece together what happened,
one of the questions that scientists like Albert zinc asked was like this cut on
his hand. Was it a fresh wound or this was already a healing wound?
Like how much time had passed between when he got the cut and when he died?
Well, we took a little a tissue piece out of the wound. They rehydrated it,
they slice it up with lasers.
We met little slices and we have a look at them and microscope and they could
see evidence that when he died,
the blood from this wound was just starting to clot,
but that it had not yet formed a scab when he died,
which told them that this attack,
this must be a warranted happened already three or four days before he died.
[inaudible]
which added another question to the list.
Like what happened in those last three or four days between the time it got cut
and the time he died. I mean,
I think this is the most fascinating thing of all about news. Jim told us.
Luckily for scientists, his intestines are wrong there.
And to the trained eye, your intestines,
it's like a mop and a diary. A diary. Yeah. Diarrhea.
In what way? If there's any food in your stomach,
it's less than photo. It was owned, which would probably be your last meal.
And this stuff in an intermediate position, like the Kulon is
between a few hours old and a few days or your last few meals.
So if you can get samples from all the years and look at the content,
you can produce all sorts of things. Um,
but one small problem, if you've got a 5,000 year old mummy on your hands,
you can't exactly just cut them open. So Jim and his team,
what they did is they snaked some fancy equipment up his butt and started
rooting around. I mean, I didn't do that. You appreciate, I'm a botanist.
I'm not. I met someone else from his team, did that. In any case,
they got up in there and first of all they couldn't find the stomach,
but they did pull out samples from the rest of his guts and they found calling
pollen pollen. Actually two kinds of pollen. One from,
from the fresh flowers of the hop horn being yes,
a tree that blooms down in the valley and Connor for pollen,
a second kind of pollen from high altitude, evergreen trees.
So you've got the high mountain, the furs and the,
the deciduous trees of the valley, of the low places. You've got the horn beam.
Both of these kinds of pollen were found in oats.
He's got probably because he drank some water, which contained the pollen.
But here's the key, the pollen from the valley,
it's sandwiched in between these two layers of mountain pollen and that implies
an order outsi must have first ingested the pine pollen,
then the horns beam and then the pine pollen again. And that suggests
about two days or so before he died, he was high up in the hill,
drinking pollinated water high above either they're the,
he was with Annie a little and below the tree line, drinking pollen,
laded water down below
and then he came back up again to meet his hand.
And so taking all of that and a couple other pieces of research here is what we
think happened to OTC in his last days.
We know that it would have been summertime,
probably June because that horn's been pollen in his gut.
Only blooms in the early summertime, in June for whatever beach.
Maybe he's hunting, maybe he's looking for copper, we don't know.
But we do know he's Hio. Alright, well above the tree line.
And then he goes by Tony's village,
which we believe was south of the mountain because certain chemicals in the
local water were also found in [inaudible] teeth and bones. Anyway,
it was not a short walk home. It's a long way diamond. It's five, 6,000 feet.
We're talking about then we know that within the span of about 24 hours,
something happens in his village. Something violent.
Maybe his people were fighting with other people where he got the details are a
little blurry, but it is clear that he was attacked,
that he put his right hand up to defend himself and that he gets that cut.
It's very deep and very bloody is very painful.
I shortly after that event,
he bends down and picks up a clump of bog moss.
Jim Actually found that bug mohs on OTC and he says that it's mildly antiseptic.
Anyway. Oh, see he heads back at the mountain. He back up again,
perhaps pursued by some body or people Pluto.
We think that maybe he was in a hurry because of the 14 hours that he was
carrying only 200 Flint tips on failures and the other 12 were useless,
which suggests a frantic state. I mean,
you've got a guy who's running bleeding and he's busily carving his arrows,
carving as he runs in for about a day or maybe a day and a half.
He's running a lot like he, we know that he runs over 12 miles,
that he gets up above 10,000 feet above sea level managing to evade whoever it
is that's coming after him. But then
the fatal Otto shot,
this is the official report from the South Tyrol Museum of Archeology.
We can see that the point of the Arrow tore a hole in the artery beneath his
left collarbone, which led to a massive hematomas, bled into the thorax cavity,
which in turn caused cardiac arrest and sudden death.
He bled to death. He would have died in less than half an hour. Really?
He would have died in 20 minutes perhaps.
And according to a lot of researchers,
whoever killed Bootsie came over,
pulled the Arrow shaft out of ocs back,
picked up a big stone and bashed his head in
[inaudible].
And then within about an hour, maybe two,
his body would have been completely covered in snow.
Then within a month or so that snow would have become ice,
and then when the next summer came around,
that ice would have thought out just enough to allow a little sunlight to come
through.
[inaudible]
the next winter he would have froze again following summer,
thought a little bit and then froze again
and then thought,
and here's why that's important. Bodies that are completely frozen deteriorate.
Those periods of thought kept him from deteriorating.
So you had this perfect mixture throughout all these years.
A season of snow, a season of ice,
and then a thought and then the snow and then the nice and then a thought.
I mean, just think about it,
year in and year out in the snow and ice throughout the building of the
pyramids, the rise and fall of Rome, the enlightenment,
the industrial revolution. All of this time,
let's see,
was there and that spot just a few feet away from where he was murdered
until 1991 when a couple of German hikers decided to head off trail
[inaudible].
We have forensic proof of his suffering. We have forensic proof of his hunger.
We have forensic evidence that he was cold. I mean,
we have all of this undeniable,
irrefutable forensic evidence that this man was a living human being who was
tormented and was enduring with incredible tenacity.
And in the last few years, scientists have still been at it.
They've still been poking it out, see, trying to figure out who was this guy,
not just who mighty have been, but who was he really.
I think there's a hope that something will be found which will say yes,
he was a hero. Yes, he was a king. Yes, he was a fodder.
I think there's this hunger on the part of the researchers to find,
to find something. Yeah.
Beyond the biology, beyond the molecular chemistry, to find some sense of the,
of the humanity. And in the year since we spoke with Jim Dixon,
scientists did find something which for Aaron at least does give him that sense.
In 2010 they found his stomach, which Jim and his team,
they couldn't find because it was tucked deep up under his rib cage,
pressed up against his heart.
They find the stomach and inside one and a half pounds of undigested goat meat
and bread in his belly. His last meal,
Oh,
this was eaten on the day of his death, maybe just an hour before he died.
It was a huge feast.
And for Aaron imagining old sees sitting at that fire right before he died.
That's what did it. Oh, I can see it. He's eating. He cooked his food.
We have proof. He, he cooked the meat and he sat down and it must've taken time.
It took at least an hour or two. Like I can feel it. I'm in the cave.
I'm on by the fire. That's what brought him back.
So you're saying then that some hours before he had somehow the time to build a
fire catch or acquire or carry a fairly substantial meal and sit and eat it
somewhat at rest. So he, he must not have known what was coming was, can we?
Well, he might, maybe he knew it.
Maybe he had found some kind of resolution around it.
But we have forensic proof that for this brief moment in time,
the Alpine ice man felt safe enough to [inaudible] to stew his meat and his
bread and sit by the fire and eat his dinner.
[inaudible].